У давні часи завжди казали,
що на територіях,
де росте виноград, Бог дав вино.
А на територіях, де росте зерно,
Бог дав пиво.
Зважаючи на те, що наш регіон
абсолютно не є виноградним,
значить у нас було пиво.
Це продукт, який був
на цих теренах дуже давно.
І, ймовірно, в силу тих історичних подій,
які відбувалися на нашій території,
ми, напевне, ніколи не дізнаємося,
наскільки глибоко сягає
історія пива саме тут.
Займаємося ми з моєю родиною
пивоварінням.
На околиці селища
міського типу Великі Бірки.
Варимо тут пиво вже 8 років,
саме на цьому місці.
І варимо те, що подобається собі і,
відповідно, те й пропонуємо людям.
Козова — це моє рідне містечко,
у якому я народився.
Наша Козова має потужну історію.
І безпосередньо з цим місцем
пов'язана її алкогольна частина.
Частина, яка, я вважаю, має право
на життя і на продовження.
Це — одне з найстаріших
укріплень Козови.
Тут, на цьому місці, у перебудованій
будівлі і варилося пиво,
і була панська ґуральня.
Броварня, свого часу, була при
кожному панському фільварку.
Варили у фільварку пиво,
безпосередньо, для власного споживання.
У 2014 році я відкрив
невеличке кафе в центрі міста.
Мені випадково потрапило
на очі оголошення
про продаж обладнання
для домашнього пивоваріння.
Порадившись з батьком,
ми таки вирішили спробувати
варити пиво самостійно.
Ми знаходимося на території
«Микулинецького Бровара».
Достеменно відомо, що раніше
пивзавод у кінці ХІХ-го століття —
на початку ХХ-го століття,
як і землі Західної України,
входили до складу Австро-Угорщини.
Власниками цього заводу
були графи Реї.
Завод працював з того часу
не зупиняючись,
навіть у періоди війни завод працював.
Фактично він переходив з рук до рук,
як і землі Західної України.
Ми виготовляємо близько
20 сортів пива.
Тут нам реклами не потрібно: тут люди
знають з чого виробляється пиво.
У когось родичі працюють на вирощуванні ячменю,
у когось в пивоварні працюють.
Тобто тут іде така...
На довірі все робиться.
Основною складовою будь-якого пива
є, в першу чергу, солод.
Він, насправді, візуально нічим не
відрізняється від звичайного зерна.
Єдина його відмінність у тому,
що він всередині — солодкий,
а не такого складу як борошно.
Його можна відчути лише на смак.
Це одна складова.
А друга складова, яка найбільше
на сьогоднішій день оцінюється...
Не те що оцінюєтся, а відчувається
в пиві, у звичайних сортах пива,
але насправді вона виступає
лише приправою.
Друга складова — це хміль.
У нашому випадку ми використовуємо
гранульований хміль,
запакований у вакуумне паковання.
Це дозволяє максимально якісно
зберегти властивості хмелю.
Ми використовуємо лише
український як солод, так і хміль.
Тобто, у нашому випадку,
варимо лише з української сировини.
Процес пивоваріння починається
з процесу підготовки подрібнення солоду.
Будь-яке пиво, в основному, вариться з,
так званого, базового солоду.
Це є звичайний ячмінний
світлий солод.
Це — пророщений ячмінь.
Далі ми маємо тут карамельний солод.
Він дає присмак паленого цукру
і дає такий темний колір.
Доволі цікавий, я його дуже люблю
і дуже багато використовую.
Шоколадний солод.
Він дає дуже класний темний колір і
надає своєрідний
кавово-шоколадний присмак пиву.
Використовується в приготуванні
темного пива.
Це зерносховище, у якому зберігається
вже після жнив ярий ячмінь перед тим,
як потрапити на солодовню.
Тобто ми контролюємо весь процес
від початку і до кінця,
щоб мати якісний солод
для виробництва пива.
Після відлежування ячмінь потрапляє
на калібрування й очищення.
Після двох днів замочування
він потрапляє на грядки,
де сім днів проростає на грядках.
Під час процесу пророщування
всі поживні речовини,
які є в ячмені, оцукрюються.
Опісля, дріжджі, поїдаючи ці цукри,
виділяють вуглекислоту і алкоголь.
Це і є процес бродіння.
Пиво — це, можна сказати,
зерновий відвар.
При температурі 45°C — 48°C я засипаю
подрібнений солод у варочник.
І ми його вже відправляємо
у подорож по температурах.
Все. Як то кажуть:
«Як мама зварила борщик,
вона накриває його кришечкою».
[Закриває солод кришкою.]
Тепер лише будемо контролювати,
час-від-часу,
скільки цукру з нього виварилося,
як він [солод] йде по часу і
по температурах собі проходить.
У мого тестя була ідея та
було бажання варити пиво.
І, насправді, все почалося
саме з його ідеї.
Найбільш відповідально до процесу
варіння ставиться моя дружина.
Вона займається, безпосередньо
процесом варіння.
А вже більш загальні організаційні
питання розподіляються між усіма іншими.
І, насправді, не мають
якоїсь усталеної форми.
Легко займатися тією справою,
яка тобі подобається.
І для мене пиво — це робота,
яка подобається.
Моя справа — це моє життя.
Тому що 80% свого часу
я присвячую своїй роботі.
Мені подобається, я цим живу.
Просто...
Я отримую задоволення від цього.
Після того, як ми зварили пиво,
коли ми вже його охолодили,
ми додаємо туди дріжджі і
переміщуємо його на бродіння.
У нас тут температура підтримується,
зараз 22°C.
Коли воно пройде певне бродіння,
ми підмішуємо праймер.
Це може бути незброджене,
свіжозварене сусло.
Це може бути... Для медового пива,
наприклад, ми підмішуємо в пиво мед.
Тобто пиво, яке ми маємо,
закінчує бродіння безпосередньо
у фінальній тарі.
І вуглекислий газ
не є штучно насичений,
а натуральний, отриманий
у процесі бродіння.
Малі, середні і крафтові броварні цінні,
в першу чергу, тим,
що вони підтримують
різні галузі виробництва.
Тобто ми закуповуємо український хміль,
ми вирощуємо свій ячмінь.
Біля нашого виробництва, відходи від пивоваріння —
ми розвиваємо тваринництво.
І люди мають можливість скуштувати,
порівняти і вибрати саме українського
виробника, а не імпорт.
Це — пшеничне пиво, яке частково,
на 50%, вариться з пшеничного солоду.
Відповідно, воно має смакові
властивості не лише ячменного солоду,
а й пшеничного.
Це один з сортів, який дуже
популярний у Німеччині.
Він називається [німецькою]
«Пшеничне пиво».
Але в Україні він є менш популярний,
ніж звичайні світлі сорти.
Тим не менше, зараз дуже багатьом
подобається саме такий смак.
«Темне медове» — це один із
найпопулярніших сортів нашого пива,
який має смак і меду, і темного пива.
Відповідно, дуже багатьом подобається.
І саме цей сорт пива дуже часто
стає несподіваним для людей,
тому що люди кажуть, що вони
не люблять темне пиво.
Але саме наше «Темне медове»
їм дуже подобається.
Слава про Тернопільське пиво
по Україні є, воно цінується.
Відомими є як і більші пивоварні,
так і про маленькі багато вже хто знає.
З Володимиром з Козови, так,
ми знайомі, спілкуємося.
Він варить інші сорти пива,
які мені дуже подобаються.
Але я ще такі не навчився варити.
Це, напевне, найпопулярніше наше
пиво — «Золота коза».
Ми в Козовій, у нас щороку
проводиться фестиваль «Коза Фест».
Це пиво [«Золота коза»] взагалі було
зварене для цього фестивалю.
До речі, цей фестиваль мав би відбудится вже сьогодні,
якби не було карантину та обмежень.
Якраз би по часу зараз
тривав парад кіз.
Так.
Якраз 13 година — у нас парад кіз.
Стандартно, вже би кози у віночках
йшли нашою центральною площею.
І, відповідно, збирається
дуже багато людей.
Гарне дійство, свято,
де ми обираємо кращу козу Козови.
Зараз будемо дегустувати.
Бачите, воно має такий
гарний золотавий колір.
Гарну пінку.
Можна!
Це мій батько — Ігор.
Людина, на яку 100%, можна
покладатись у будь-який момент.
Без його меду не було б нашого
медового пива, це найголовніше. [сміється]
Пасіка — це більше його «парафія».
Тато тоді сказав класну фразу:
«Якщо нічого не вийде з кафе,
то не страшно — будемо пити вдома».
Я вважаю, що в нас дуже багато
перспектив у цьому плані.
Тобто ми можемо не гірше
виробляти той чи інший продукт.
Тому що в нас є всі умови для цього.
Собівартість виробництва
набагато нижча, ніж в Європі.
Найкращі, фактично, врожаї
пивоварних сортів ячменю,
з яких ми можемо
виробляти пиво не гірше,
ніж у баварських і чеських виробників.
Перш за все, що може зробити кожен
для розвитку України, — це жити тут,
знайти свою нішу,
свою улюблену справу.
І робити цю справу добре для того,
щоб розвивати кожне своє місто,
кожне своє село.
Я намагався завжди працювати
для того, щоб жити тут.
Я тут вдома.
Я люблю Козову, люблю Тернопіль,
бо вони комфортні і в них класно.